[Music]
so Monday was my 41st birthday and this
helium inflated stormtrooper showed up
at my door and I couldn't possibly pass
up the opportunity to use him as both a
prop and a metaphor for this week's
direct message one of the ideas which
keeps popping up in the discussions
we're having around here is that old
political labels are becoming more and
more meaningless by the day the terms
progressive and liberal have virtually
nothing to do with each other anymore
and if you're a classical liberal you're
certainly not elected conservative and
Republican don't have much to do with
each other today as Trump a populist
who doesn't focus on social issues like
gay marriage and legalizing marijuana is
now the leader of the GOP for these
reasons as well as the real-time
crumbling of our mainstream media the
battle for freedom now is between the
authoritarians and the libertarians that
is the battle over the soul of America
and the West in general is now about
people who want the government to have
more control over your life versus the
people who want the government to have
less control over your life I think that
by now you probably know that I fall
solidly in the camp of the people who
want the government to have less control
over how you live and that brings me to
my friendly and trusty stormtrooper
beside me in the original 1977 Star Wars
the stormtroopers were the foot soldiers
for the Galactic Republic a massive evil
military regime who wanted to control
every star system in the galaxy this
would qualify as authoritarian the
Empire and the stormtroopers were not
keepers of the peace as the emperor had
promised but authoritarian rulers who
wanted to endlessly expand their power
hence their building of the Death Star
to blow up any planet which didn't fall
in line with their desires blowing up a
planet is a pretty good way to get
people to do what you want now there I
talk about the prequels but trust me it
works for this metaphor 2002 Star Wars
Episode two attack of the clones takes
place about 20 years before the original
Star Wars in this film the stormtroopers
at that time known as the clone troopers
were the good guys they allied with the
Jedi
defense of the Democratic Republic
eventually Chancellor Palpatine who had
consolidated power himself and secretly
ordered the creation of the Clone Army
took control of the stormtroopers and
the Senate and used democracy against
itself at the same time going from
chancellor to emperor in 2015 the force
awakens which takes place about twenty
years after the original trilogy the
stormtroopers are again the bad guys
this time in the form of the soldiers
for the authoritarian first order which
has risen from the ashes of the Galactic
Republic one of the heroes of the story
Finn is a stormtrooper gone rogue who
suddenly realizes that he as an end of
individual can chart his own destiny he
puts his collectivist past as a
stormtrooper behind him
and he becomes one of the heroes of the
story the point of all of this is that
it isn't this stormtrooper you should
fear it's the power which commands him
any ideology can be used as a force for
good or for evil and that's why we
should be raining in authoritarianism of
any kind even when it's your sort of
authoritarianism in charge this whole
metaphor took place in a galaxy far far
away but the lessons that it presents
are ones we can use right here on earth
joining me to discuss authoritarianism
vers libertarianism is author professor
and podcaster Thaddeus Russel our
friends who learn Liberty of centum our
way and too loosely quote obi-wan Kenobi
this is the episode you've been looking
for
you
[Music]